so i really love sony cameras but
sometimes the colors are just not right
there
what about canon
can we have canon colors on sony cameras
let's try it out
the curves tab go to hue versus hue and
shift yellow towards pink and green
towards blue in the here versus
saturation bring yellow all the way down
and red just a tiny bit
you can already see this was causing
most of the problem in the hue versus
luma bring up yellow just a bit and
bread by 30 percent up
next step drop the kelvin by 500 to 1000
drop the tint by minus 30. now let's
saturate just a tiny bit and adjust the
contrast with the curves tool
[Music]
soft clipping to preserve details and
shadows and highlights
and now some creative work add some cyan
in the shadows and yellow in the
highlights
there we go before and after who said
you can't color grade 8-bit footage
by the way if you want better color out
of the camera i made 7 custom film
simulations for sony cameras and i'll be
making a video about them soon so don't
forget to subscribe
also many thanks to my friend for
modeling for me today go check his
channel to see his cycling adventures
and bike hacks
that's it for today see in the next one
[Music]
you